on the 6th of January 2021 unprecedented
scenes unfolded at the heart of
America's democratic system on Capitol
Hill in Washington DC protesters stormed
the corridors of the 200 year old
building as lawmakers hid and police
were overrun
five people died and president Donald
Trump accused of inciting the violence
was impeached for a second time and
suspended from social media
so a year later what's changed there are
a lot of different opinions among
Americans about January 6. polarization
has actually worsened in America the
threat of far-right extremism has become
even more pronounced and where has this
left Donald Trump and trumpism we
absolutely can see a trump 2024 come
back
[Music]
the January the sixth riots followed a
rally in front of the White House where
then president Trump urged his
supporters to March towards the capital
complex we will never
United in their mission to as they put
it stop the steal after Joe Biden was
declared the winner of the 2020 election
[Applause]
a year later and contrary to the facts
Donald Trump's position is unchanged in
our view in my view the big lie is that
Joe Biden got 81 million votes the most
in history and yet now he's at a what 22
percent of people want him to run again
former president Trump is still
absolutely of the belief that he won the
election in 2020. yeah absolutely and
you look at it even though even though
64 out of 65 challenges in courts around
this nation
when there have been recounts and
recounts
and that they have they have done
they've checked very clearly
and those have been proven to be very
fair elections or Fair counts
a box
lbox recounts are very different than
Audits and what we see so they've been
audits as well a House of
Representatives committee is undertaking
a massive inquiry into the capital riots
I can feel my
myself losing oxygen and recall thinking
to myself
this is how I'm going to die 350
Witnesses have been interviewed 52
subpoenas sent and over 35
000 pages of Records received the
committee in some ways has a bit of a
limited mandate in terms of what they
can do but there's two main Pathways one
which is slightly more doubtful is to
make what would be called a criminal
referral and this would be essentially
referring someone perhaps even former
president Trump himself to the
Department of Justice for criminal
proceeding and that would be if they
felt that there was enough evidence to
show that Trump intentionally obstructed
the official proceeding of the election
count that's one move but it's one that
would be very controversial I think what
we're more likely to see is that the
committee will suggest changes to some
of the legislation that currently
defines how we count our elections so
changes to what's called our electoral
account act to make it a bit more
progress and try and prevent some of the
loopholes that Trump and some of his
associates tried to exploit
inquiry has revealed that some of those
close to Mr Trump including Fox News
presenter Sean Hannity as well as Mr
Trump's own son Don Jr
urged him to intervene
as all this was unfolding records show
that Don Jr wrote a text message to
White House Chief of Staff Mark Meadows
saying that this has gone too far
over the past year Donald Trump has
remained in constant campaign mode my
fellow Americans are moved it is far
from over in fact our fight has only
just begun he's continued to claim
against all facts but to audiences who
believe him that the election was stolen
so what next for the former president we
absolutely could see a trump 2024 come
back and if you look at the full chess
board at the moment I think it's even a
likely scenario it's hard to imagine any
scenario in which if Trump wants the
Republican nomination he won't get it so
everything we see from Trump also
suggests that he's gearing up for a
return he's issuing press releases he's
holding rallies he's trying to keep
himself generally in the news Joe Biden
promised to unite to divide in America
but one year on from what's now simply
known as January the sixth America's
political landscape is as polarized as
ever in this year of the crucial midterm
elections American politics is as
exciting as it is alarming